hey what's up Tonya Dwyer from GameSpot
calm here with mr. Andy Bauman hey hey
hey how you doing dude dude I'm good we
played four to six I'm stoked we sure
did last week we're gonna talk about it
today yeah well what are the main
differences I guess you got from our
time playing career mode for two hours
last week
all right good question I broke down to
three distinct little modules here we're
gonna go through first one they have
these things called mod cards yeah so
before each race you kind of you collect
these cards and you can you can use them
what what do they do exactly alright so
there's three categories there's like a
crew card a boost cart and a dare card
and crew cards have a limited use but
you can only equip one at a time and
they do things like 4% better braking 3%
better traction 6% on Yas Marina better
traction so it's like little little
things that give you a leg up without
pushing your car class higher yeah then
the green ones which are boost just give
you like more XP or more affinity or if
you do a really cool draft you get like
more and more and more XP or and then
there's dares which we didn't actually
see but that got told about them and
those like give you a worse starting
position and if you win you get like a
boost of more cash rewards that's pretty
cool but that kind of builds that kind
of fits into like how 4 it's a works
wood like it's difficulty and assists
right you always get boost like the
party you go with one of the things I
liked was the showcase events that's
kind of how I play games like project
cars where it's like oh hey you know
what his career mode you can do that but
then these showcase events they're kind
of like designed for you to just get a
taste of the other types of racing so we
were in career mode and there was one
that was basically like IndyCar it
unlocked during the career mode really
early on and it was like hey step into
the shoes of an IndyCar racer and go
seven laps on the you know the
Indianapolis track at 200 miles per hour
which in four to six is just amazing fun
yeah ridiculous there was an also
another one in there which we can't show
footage on sadly which was driving
formerly cars ran to super
Street circuit as well and I enjoyed
that quite a lot bring one of the things
I remember you tell me about for to
horizon 2 was the the wheel the spin
wheel right and that's kind of in six as
well alright so six has they promised us
a way more forgiving or giving economy
because five the economy was stingy as
hell yeah
and in this one within the first two
levels you do a spin like in horizon and
you have a one in nine shot of either
winning a Bugatti or a million credits
and it shows you what's on the spin as
well it doesn't it scope it lands in the
middle and it's a grid of three by three
so it's not even that like you out of
the question you're gonna get out either
a two million dollar car right off the
bat our million credits like I got yeah
you did right right at the first so like
they're already kind of saying like look
we're sorry we're sorry about four to
five here have a have a Bugatti right
off the bat yeah and and that economy
kind of ties back into what they're
doing with the cards too because to get
cards you buy packs of gum odd cars oh
and they're tiered and the highest tier
one was three hundred thousand for like
six cards and you go through and you
like unveil them like you're buying some
sort of hearthstone pack or two it is
like FIFA Ultimate Team all over again
that's like they're really gamifying
that suit but it was cool i it's a good
way to spend your idle credits because
like once you do win a million like what
do you do buy a Bugatti I guess and the
game like it seemed like a sort of a
full feature you were kind of saying it
felt like while four to five should have
been right correct more fully for more
tracks night more training night the
rain stuff is really cool like I'm
actually super into that I add one stage
I didn't like ridiculous like no assist
Formula one cars and spa in the rain and
I went up a Rouge hit a puddle and just
[ __ ] good night Irene straight in
school yeah it was good fun I enjoyed it
yeah and one thing that stood out to me
was the grass on the tracks looks way
better so that's if you want graphical
improvement that's what you're getting
better grass you get off on grass and
puddles four to six horizon motorcars as
your back wait wait no sorry the demo is
actually out today the embargo for the
stuff lifted today September 1st ed
playable demo is ready for you to play
if you do pick up that demo you get a
Ford GT
you do end up purchasing the game for
free so there's another like example the
Ford GT the the poster color yeah
exactly the Ford GT the cover athlete
yes
four to six and then the full game is
added on the 15th of September that's
right but if you're like me and you're
gonna drop $100 I might not do it well
you get it on the 10th oh really
yeah it really on early a little bit of
an incentive there and you get a bunch
of cars with that tooth or whatever yeah
so we'll have the full review car lists
you know videos of form of the e cars
and all that stuff up on gamespot.com
over the coming weeks I'll stay tuned
thanks man for having thanks Andy
let's go race